lui la pédiatrie est à genoux les
enfants sont en danger je me joins c'est
moi dressés par plus de 7000 soignants
au président de la République il y a
quelques jours quelques semaines depuis
quelques semaines nos services
pédiatriques sont en sont saturés les
bébés sont transférés à plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres de chez eux et
tous les jours des soins importants sont
des programmés le problème ne date pas
d'hier que sont devenus les
préconisations de la mission flash de
l'IGAS publiée en 2019 et son rapport
paru en 2021 je vous les redonne
avez-vous amélioré la gestion du plan
hivernal et la gestion des alertes la
réponse est non avez-vous facilité le
recrutement et la fidélisation des
infirmiers et puéricultrice en soins
critiques la réponse est toujours non
pourtant vous avez les réponses alors
que les représentants de la pédiatrie
vous exhortent à des mesures
structurelles on comprend toutefois que
votre budget votre rend Damme un sincère
voté à plus de 40 93 vous contraint à
des mesurettes malheureusement
provisoire comme l'heure de nuit qui
augmentera bien mes chers collègues de 1
euro 79 rien n'a été annoncé sur la
revalorisation de la permanence des
soins par ailleurs votre calendrier est
déconnecté de la réalité et de l'urgence
avec des Assises de la pédiatrie prévue
au printemps les soignants ont lancé un
cri désespéré face à cette situation
critique engendrée par une épidémie
pourtant habituelle monsieur le ministre
alors que vous allez bientôt faire
accepter aux Français l'idée que
désormais les enfants ne pourront plus
être soignés correctement ma question
est simple est-ce que l'État va
reconnaître sa responsabilité dans ses
crises que nous traversons et ne pas la
faire porter aux soignants